gençler merhaba Hepiniz hoş geldiniz
Biyolojinin en zor konusuyla başlıyoruz
Hocam nasıl en zor konusu aslında
canlıların karakteristik özelliklerine
baktığınız zaman her şeyden
bahsettiğimiz bir video olacak Gözünüz o
yüzden korkmasın Ne yapacağız biz bütün
biyolojiyi özetleyeceğiz Canlılar
özelinde konuşacağız Tekrar uyarayım Bu
video ile sakın pes etmeyin Tamam mı biz
burada hocam aslında temelde bütün bir
yıl boyunca biyolojide bizi ne bekliyor
onu konuşacağız Yani bu konunun
sorularını kaçırabilirsin Testlerini
fulleyemeyebilirsin
Hatta birçok şey havada kalabilir Yarım
yamalak olabilir Hiç önemli değil Çünkü
birazdan göreceksin solunumdan protein
sentezinden üremeden bazı temel
kavramlardan bahsedeceğiz ve konuyu
aslında biyolojinin zeminine oturtarak
alfabe yaratacağız Canlıların
karakteristik özelliklerini virüsle aynı
başlık altında inceliyorum Aslında yeni
müfredatta da böyle yaptılar arkadaşlar
Neden çünkü bir tarafta canlıların
karakteristik özelliklerinden
bahsediyorsunuz Bir yerde de yani canlı
mı desek cansız mı desek temel kriter
nedir tarzında karşımıza çıkan bir
organizmadan bahsedeceğiz Yani
virüslerden bahsedeceğiz Biliyorsunuz ki
cansızlar ve canlılar arasındaki bir
geçişten bahsediyoruz virüslerden
konuştuğumuzda Peki bu konunun
içerisindeki bütün başlıklar anahtar
kavram olarak MEB'in kazanımlarında
geçiyor Dediğim gibi panik
yapmayacaksınız Konunun tadını
çıkartacaksınız ve bir sene boyunca
biyolojide ne öğreneceğim aslında o
mantıkla konuya yaklaşacaksınız Ne
diyoruz hadi gelin birlikte öğrenelim
Bir organizmaya canlı demek için ne tarz
bir şart lazım aslında temelde ona
bakıyoruz Bir kere hücresel yapılardan
oluşmak zorunda ve her canlı tek ya da
çok hücrelidir Bu hücre teorisinde
karşımıza çıkacak Her canlı tek ya da
çok hücrelidir Her hücre bir önceki
hücrenin bölünmesiyle meydana gelir
Hücrelerde metabolik faaliyetler
hücrenin içerisinde sitoplazmada
gerçekleşir Hücrelerde nükleik asitler
bulunur gibi Aslında arkadaşlar temel
hücre teorisi özelliklerinden
bahsedeceğiz Şimdi baktığınızda
canlıların canlılık özelliği gösteren en
küçük yapı birimi nedir tabii ki
hücredir Daha küçük yapı birimleri var
mı var elbette atomlar moleküller
organeller vesaire ama biz burada
canlılık özelliği taşıyan ifadesini
kullanıyoruz Temelinde iki tip hücre
mevcut Bunlardan birincisi prokaryot
hücre Prokaryot ne demek zarlı organel
ve çekirdek içermeyen demek Hemen
yazıyorum Zarlı organel ve çekirdek yok
Peki bunun örneği kimdir hocam
bakteriler ve arkeler Tabii ki ben
bunları bilmiyorum Sakin ol Panik yapma
Ne dedim özet yapıyoruz Bütün biyolojiyi
özetleyeceğiz Peki diğer hücre tipimiz
nedir ökaryot hücre hocam Ökaryot
hücrede o zaman zarlı organel ve
çekirdek var Güzel Kim bunlar protist
bitki
mantar
ve hayvan
İşte karşımıza çıkan ökaryot canlılar
Şimdi şuna dikkat etmenizi istiyorum Ben
size prokaryot ya da ökaryot dediğimde
sakın tek hücreli çok hücreli tarzında
bir yaklaşımda bulunmayın Prokaryotlara
baktığınızda evet bakteriler ve arkeler
arkadaşlar tek hücreli üyeler barındırır
Ancak ökaryotlarda protistler ve bazı
mantarlar tek hücreli olabilir Yani
burada hem tek hücre hem çok hücre var
Burada hem tek hücre hem çok hücre var
Böyle küçük bir not alabilirsiniz
Mantarlar içerisinde mesela tek hücreli
maya mantarı var ÖSYM sever Ancak bitki
ve hayvanlara baktığınızda bunların
arkadaşlar tamamı çok hücrelidir
İşte bunlar ileride küçük küçük
sınıflandırma soruları olarak karşımıza
çıkacak Öyleyse prokaryot ökaryot
ayrımını yaptık Prokaryot zarlı organel
ve çekirdek içermeyen ökaryot zarlı
organel ve çekirdek içeren prokaryotlar
bakteriler arkeler ökaryotlar protisler
bitkiler mantarlar ve hayvanlar olacak
Buradan metabolik faaliyetlerin hücrenin
sitoplazmasında gerçekleşmesi madde
alışverişlerinin hücre zarıyla kontrol
edilmesi dediğim gibi ileride hücre
konusu altında detaylandıracağımız
cümleler kalıtım molekülü ve nükleik
asit Aslında canlıların karakteristik
özelliklerini MEB kitabından okuduğunuz
zaman böyle spesifik başlıklar
görmeyeceksiniz Ama ben biraz daha böyle
soru tipi üzerinden de gitmek istiyorum
Çünkü en çok kaçırılan sorular genelde
buradan oluyor Canlılarda kalıtım
molekülü arkadaşlar DNA'dır Bakın dikkat
edin Ne vurgusu var burada canlı vurgusu
var Hemen altında bir ünlem Peki ya
virüs virüslerde kalıtım molekülü kim
hocam dna ya da RNA'dır Bakın ikisi
olmaz Tamam mı bazı virüsler DNA taşır
bazı virüsler RNA taşır Ama canlı
ifadesini kurguladıysa soruda canlıda
kimdir kalıtım molekülü diye bir ifade
varsa cevabın ne olacak dna olacak İşte
hücrelerin içerisinde DNA var RNA var
ribozom var sitoplazma var Öyleyse ben
aslında şuraya hemen küçük bir not
atabilirim Canlılar hücrelerden meydana
geliyorsa hücreye baktığınızda işte
hücre zarı sitoplazma dikkat ribozom
DNA
RNA şu şekilde yazdım İşte benim
hücrelerden beklediğim aslında ortak
yapılar bunlar Bunlara baktığınızda
prokaryot canlıda da ökaryot canlıda da
olduklarını göreceksiniz Ancak virüs
olursa DNA ya da RNA ki zaten birazdan
bahsedeceğim Virüslerde hücre zarı yok
virüslerde sitoplazma yok Virüslerde
metabolizma yok DNA ya da RNA var 9
sınıf okul kitabımız organizasyon için
iş bölümü ifadesini kullanıyor Aslında
organizasyon biraz daha detaylı biraz
daha geniş bir kavram Ancak biz burada
bununla yetinelim Organizasyon
dediğimizde tek hücreli bir canlıysa
aslında molekül ya da ökaryotsa organel
düzeyinde çok hücreli bir canlıysa
hücreler dokular organlar sistemler
oluşturmuşsa mesela bizim gibi işte
sistem düzeyinde organ düzeyinde bir iş
bölümü var bunu söylemeye çalışıyor Yani
aslında hücreler dokuları
dokular organları
organlar sistemleri sistemler
organizmayı meydana getirir Zaten burada
yazıyor hocam Bir şeye dikkat çekmek
için kendim de yazmak istedim Özellikle
şurada dokuya dikkat edin arkadaşlar
Doku özelleşmiş hücre yapıları hücre
kümeleri yani birlikte bir işi meydana
getirmek bir işi yapmak için hücrelerin
bir araya gelmesi Ancak bazı canlılar
doku oluşturamayıp koloni
oluşturabilirler
İşte çok hücre var Bunların arasında
belki de iş bölümü de var Ancak
kesinlikle doku oluşturmazlar Bunlar
kolonidir Karşınıza çok çıkmaz Çünkü
kolonilerin arkadaşlar anlatımı
müfredatımızda yok Yani buradan
anlamamız gereken şey şu Bazen hücreler
bir araya gelerek dokulaşmaz ama birden
fazla hücre iş bölümü ortaya koyabilir
Gelelim büyüme ve gelişmeye Tek hücreli
canlılarda sitoplazma artışı çok hücreli
canlılarda hücre artışı karşımıza büyüme
olarak gelir Şimdi eğer bir hücreden
bahsediyorsa arkadaşlar buraya çok
dikkat edin lütfen Bir hücre bölündüğü
zaman büyümüş olmaz Bir hücre bölündüğü
zaman üremiş olur çoğalmış olur O zaman
tek hücreli canlılar bölünerek
büyümezler Tek hücreli canlılarda
sitoplazma artışı kütle artışıyla büyüme
gerçekleşir Gelişme nedir yapıların
işlerlik kazanması fonksiyonlarına uygun
hale gelmesi gelişmedir Şimdi bir bebek
doğdu Bebeğin kilosunun artması boyunun
uzaması büyümedir Burada hücre sayısı
artıyor Hücrelerin kütlesi artıyor Ancak
bebeğin emeklemesi yürümesi koşması
konuşması gelişmedir Yani büyüme ve
gelişme arasındaki temel fark bakın
dikkat edin Fonksiyonlara uygun hale
gelmesi iş yapabilecek duruma gelmesi
ifadesi bana gelişmeyi gösterir Ama
tekrar edelim Çok hücreli bir canlının
büyümesinden bahsediyorsanız hücre
sayısının artması hücrelerin kütlesinin
hacminin artmasıdır Mesela biz nasıl
büyüyoruz hücre sayımızı arttırarak Ama
tek hücreli bir canlı sadece
hücresindeki sitoplazma miktarını
arttırarak büyüyebilir Yani kütlece
hacimce büyüyebilir Bölündüğü anda
büyümüş değil üremiş olur Diğer bir
maddemiz protein sentezi Şimdi yine
canlıların karakteristik özelliklerinden
bahsederken böyle bir başlık
görmeyeceksiniz ama hocam bizim derdimiz
mantığı oturtabilmek Dünyadaki bütün
canlıların protein sentezi yapmasını
beklersiniz Çünkü her canlı kendine özgü
molekül sentezlemeli enzim sentezlemeli
hücre zarına birtım maddeler eklemeli
Protein kanalları olabilir değil mi
reseptörler olabilir İçeride dediğim
gibi enzimler olabilir Dolayısıyla
protein sentezi öyleyse aslında evrensel
bir olaydır ve bunu yapan kişi de
evrenseldir Ribozom bir hücresel yapıdır
ve hücrelerin canlı hücrelerin
içerisinde fonksiyon göstermesini
beklersiniz prokaryot da olsa ökaryot da
olsa Peki bana bu bilgiyi bilmek neleri
çözdürebilir eğer protein sentezinin
mantığını biliyorsam yani n tane amino
asit yan yana gelecek Proteini
sentezleyeceğim ve n -1 tane su çıkacak
Buradaki n -1 muhabbetini arkadaşlar
şöyle söyleyebilirim 5 parmağınız var 4
tane boşluğunuz var Bu ne demek mesela
amino asit amino asit amino asit amino
asit aminoasit yan yana geldi 5 tane
bakın 1 2 3 4 tane bağ oluşur
Dolayısıyla bağa kadar su çıkar Size su
ve bağ sorularını öğreteceğim zaman
dehidrasyonda bunu düşüneceksiniz Ne
kadar bağ varsa o kadar su açığa çıkar
Şimdi özümüze dönelim Hocam ben protein
sentezinin denklemini yazdım Sadece bu
denkleme bakarak hangi soruları
çözebilirim mesela canlılar
kendilerine özgü
molekül sentezleyebilir
Aslında tabii ki buradan kastımız sadece
protein sentezi değil DNA sentezi RNA
sentezi protein sentezi Burada canlı
kendine özgü molekül sentezlemiş oluyor
Çünkü hepsi dikkat edin DNA temelli ve
her canlının kendi DNA şifresi var Peki
başka ne söyleyebilirim hocam bu tepkime
enzimatik
Enzim kullanımı canlılarda ortaktır
Bu bir dehidrasyon tepkimesi Bu ne demek
hocam küçük moleküller bir araya gelerek
büyük molekülleri meydana getirmiş ve
açığa su çıkmış Dehidrasyon Su atmak
Dolayısıyla
dehidrasyon tepkimesini katalizleme
her canlıda ortak Ama hocam bir de
dehidrasyon tepkimesi sırasında ATP
tüketilir değil mi harika O zaman ATP
tüketimi
ki bunun bilimsel adı defosforilasyon
Bu da ortak Öyleyse bir tane özellik
yani canlının protein sentezleyebilme
özelliğinden ben hangi soruları
çözebildim 1 Canlıların tamamında
dehidrasyon var 2 Defosforilasyon var 3
Enzim kullanımı var 4 Kendine özgü
molekül sentezleme özelliği var İşte
buradan arkadaşlar bu tarz soruları
çözeceğiz Ribozomun temel yapısına
baktım Bunu sadece burada görmüş olun
arkadaşlar iki alt birimden meydana
geliyor Küçük alt birim ve büyük alt
birim ve protein sentez sırasında bu alt
birimler bir araya geliyor Gelelim
homeostaziyye
Homeostazi kararlı ortam iç denge demek
Yani dar alanlar içerisinde dar sınırlar
içerisinde canlılık faaliyetlerini devam
ettirmek demek Bizim için konuşalım yine
Çünkü karşımıza eğer AYT'ye de
girecekseniz bunlar çıkacak Özellikle
bizim kan pH'ımız 7.4 civarında 6.9 7.8
hayatla bağdaşmaz Vücut sıcaklığımız
36,5 s d 40 derece ya da 32 derece
hayatla bağdaşmaz Kanımızın ozmotik
basıncı yaklaşık 290 civarında milioz
mol/ Lre Yine bunun çok üstü ve çok altı
hayatla bağdaşmaz Yani biz aslında küçük
dar sınırlar içerisinde yaşıyoruz ve bu
sınırları sürekli sağlamaya çalışıyoruz
Mesela bunlardan bir tanesi ve başrol
oyuncusu hipotalamus Vücut sıcaklığımız
değiştiğinde kanımızın ozmotik basıncı
değiştiğinde bunu algılar Buradaki
detaylara çok takılmayın Yine okul
kitabı özelinde yazdım bunları Mesela
çok susadınız Diyelim ki su içmediniz ya
da çok fazla terlediniz Bir susama hissi
oluştu İşte o sırada hipotalamus bunu
algılar Der ki kanımızın ozmotik basıncı
değişti Su içmemiz lazım Ya da vücut
sıcaklığınız düştü Bunu yükseltmemiz
lazım Ya da kanımızın pH'ı değişti Hemen
beyin sapına sinyal gider Omurlik soğan
ve pons der ki aa kan pH'ı düşmüş
solunumun derinliğini ve hızını
arttıralım Bu sayede işte o saydığım dar
alanlar içerisine birtım değerlerimiz
çekilmiş olunur Peki bunu yaparken
yararlandığımız
sistemler hangileri hocam neredeyse
tamamından yararlanıyoruz Şimdi
homeostaziyi hangi sistem doğrudan
kontrol eder tarzında eski bir sorumuz
vardı ama onu bilerek kaldırdım artık
sinir sistemi endokrin sistem tabii ki
solunum sistemi dolaşım sistemi Dolaylı
olarak destek hareket sistemi girer
diyordum eskiden Tabii ki yine kemik
iliklerini düşündüğümüzde kan yapımı
vesaire Bu da yani bir bütün olarak
düşünmek adına vücudumuzdaki bütün
sistemler sonuçta bizi hayatta tutmak
için bir şekilde çalışıyorlar Neden
gereklidir boşaltım biz ne diyoruz amaç
fazla
ve veya artık maddeleri atarak
homeostaziyi sağlamak
Yani iç denge kararlı ortamı sağlamak
Bakın dikkat edin Bir maddenin vücuttan
atılması için onun zehirli ya da artık
olması şartı yok aslında Fazlaysa da
atmamız lazım Çünkü her şeyin fazlası
zarar Yani siz fazla su içtiyseniz fazla
tuz aldıysanız fazla vitamin aldıysanız
bunların hepsi zarar Yağda çözünen
vitaminlerin aşırısı karaciğerde
zehirlenmeye neden olabilir mesela Ya da
fazla su kanınızın ozmotik basıncını
değiştirebilir kişiyi öldürebilir
Dolayısıyla fazla olan su fazla olan
mineral yani bir başka ifadeyle tuz ya
da fazla olan iyon fazla olan vitamin
vesaire bunların atılması lazım Artıklar
tamam herkesin aklına gelebilir Amonyak
gibi üre gibi ürik asit gibi ya da ilaç
artıkları gıda boyaları
mesela penisilin artığı diyelim
Dolayısıyla arkadaşlar bunları atıyorum
ve neyi sağlamış oluyorum homeostaziyi
sağlamış oluyorum Bu sayede yaşamım
devam ediyor Peki boşaltımın örnekleri
nelerdir birkaç canlıdan bahsedelim
Sadece insan özelinde gitmeyelim Mesela
yaprak dökmek bir boşaltım örneğidir
Elbette yaprak dökmenin başka fizyolojik
nedenleri de var Mesela yüzey alanını
azaltmak terlemeyi azaltmak vesaire kışa
girerken Ancak yaprakta biriken zehirli
maddelerden artıklardan bitki aynı
zamanda bu şekilde uzaklaşır ya da
kendini bunlardan arındırır
Bu canlıya baktığımız zaman kimi
görüyoruz paramesyum bu Hocam ben bu
canlıyı tanımıyorum Olsun bir kere duy
Ne diyorum sarmal model uyguluyoruz Bir
cümleyi 5 defa 6 defa duyacaksınız ve
artık bunu içselleştireceksiniz
Paramesum öglena amip gibi canlılar yani
tatlı sularda yaşayan tek hücreli
canlılar içeriye giren fazla su onların
hücresini parçalamasın diye Bakın dikkat
edin Burada bir yapı var Biz buna
kontraktil koful diyoruz Yaz hocam
Kontraktil koful Tabii ki bunu ileride
göreceğiz yine organellerde contraction
kasılmak demek Bu koful kasılarak içeri
giren fazla suyu dışarı atıyor ve
canlının parçalanmasını engellemiş
oluyor İşte bakın burada homeostazi
sağlanmış oluyor Başka ne örnek
verebiliriz hocam biraz insandan
konuşabiliriz şimdi Mesela terleme
mesela idrar atma mesela karbondioksiti
dışarı atma Bunlar arkadaşlar boşaltım
boşaltıma yardımcı olaylardır
Karaciğerimizin safra üretmesi Safra
sonuçta birtım artık maddelerden
üretilen bir madde ve bunu bağırsaklar
aracılığıyla vücuttan uzaklaştırması Bu
da eklenebilir ama dediğim gibi
detaylarda şimdi boğulmayalım En önemli
ve öncelikle sorulacak şeylere
odaklanalım Bir diğer ifade etkiye tepki
gösterme Bütün canlılar çevrelerinde ve
içlerinde olan olaylara bir şekilde
tepki göstermek zorunda Buradaki
tepkiden kastımız sadece hareket etme
yer değiştirme ya da bağırma çağırma
değil Moleküler seviyeyi de
düşünebilirsiniz Yani bir hormon
üretilmiştir O hormon gider bir hücreye
reseptörüne bağlanır ve birtım
tepkimeler başlatabilir Yani sizin onu
illa gözle görmenize gerek yok
baktığınız zaman canlı organizmanın
dışından ya da içinden gelen uyarılara
karşı gösterdiği kimi zaman moleküler
temelli kimi zaman ise gözle görülebilen
davranışlar etkiye tepki gösterme Bakın
buradaki görselimiz küstüm motile
alakalı Küstüm otuna dokunduğunuz zaman
arkadaşlar ne yapıyor yapraklarını
kapatıyor ya da böcek kapan bitkisi
Böcek kapan bitkisi kendisine böcek
değdiği anda yapraklarını kapatıyor ve
ondan yararlanmanın yoluna gidiyor İşte
burada etkiye tepki davranışı var
aslında Harekete baktığımızda bunu çoğu
zaman görmeyebilirsiniz ama yer
değiştirme ırganım yönelim şeklinde
ayırdım Şimdiden bize lazım olanlar
mesela yer değiştirme bir yerden bir
yere gitme taksis kelimesiyle arkadaşlar
ifade edilirken ırganım ve yönelim
aslında durum değiştirme hareketidir
Yani yer değiştirme hareketi değil
Irganıma arkadaşlar nasti yönelime ise
tropizma diyeceğiz ileride Özellikle
bitkilerle alakalı konuştuğumuz zaman
mesela uyaranın yönüne bağlı olan
hareketler tropizma olacak fototropizma
geotropizma hidrotropizma bunları yazma
lütfen Ya da uyaranın yönüne bağlı
olmayan turgor basınç değişimleriyle
ortaya çıkan sismonasti termonasti
fotonasti şeklinde olaylar olacak Yani
burada bir hareket aslında etki tepki
sonucu olabilir Fakat hemen şuraya şöyle
küçük bir ünlem atmak istiyorum
arkadaşlar Her canlı yer değiştirme
hareketi yapmak zorunda değil Gördüğünüz
gibi mesela bitkilerde hocam durum
değiştirme hareketi var dediniz En çok
düşülen soruyu söyleyeyim mi bütün
hayvanlar yer değiştirme hareketi yapar
mı yapmaz hocam Sınıflandırmada mesela
ben size süngerleri anlatacağım ya da
bazı sölenterlerden hidra gibi onlardan
bahsedeceğim Demek ki bütün hayvanlar
yer değiştirme hareketi yapar tarzında
bir soru olursa ne olacak bunun cevabı
yanlış olacak Lütfen şuraya yazalım
Bütün hayvanlar yer değiştirme hareketi
yapar mı cevap hayır Sünger
sölenterlerden bazıları Ne zaman tekrar
gelecek bu bilgi karşıma sınıflandırmada
ya da birazdan checkpoin'e tekrar bunu
söyleriz Gelelim metabolizma ve bazal
metabolizmaya Organizmalarda görülen tüm
yapım yıkım ve dönüşüm tepkimelerine ne
denir hocam metabolizma Dönüşüm ne demek
hocam dönüşüm yani bir maddeyi başka bir
maddeye çevirmek Mesela ileride
söyleyeceğiz Aminoasitlerden glikoz
üretilebilir Glikozlar yağlara
dönüşebilir Ama genelde neye
odaklanıyorlar bakın yapım
anabolizma
özümleme
ve sentez ifadesi olarak karşımıza
çıkıyor Yıkım katabolizma
yadımlama olarak karşımıza çıkıyor Hocam
örnekler verebilir misin tabii ki Mesela
özümleme sentez Kimdir bunlar işte
fotosentez olabilir ya da bir protein
sentezi dehidrasyon tepkimeleri olabilir
kemosentez olabilir Yadımlama yıkıma
örnekler ne olabilir hocam solunum bir
yıkım olayıdır Hidroliz bir yıkım
olayıdır Bunları detaylandırmıyorum
İleride zaten hepsinin alt başlıklara
ayrıldığını göreceksiniz Canlıların
hayatta kalmak için ihtiyaç duydukları
enerji miktarı nedir peki bazal
metabolizma
Yani ben hiçbir şey yapmasam bile bazal
metabolizmam bana şunu anlatır Benim
vücudum şu anda kendisini hayatta
tutabilmek için enerji harcıyor Mesela
midem boş yemek yemedim ama bu mide
hücrelerimin enerji harcamadığı anlamına
gelmez ya da bağırsaklarım Zaten
durduğunuz yerde beyniniz enerjinin
neresi %40'ını 50'sini harcıyor İşte
canlının aslında organlarının hayatta
kalmak için harcadığı enerji bazal
metabolizmaya karşılık gelir Ve
diyetisyenler endokrinoloji uzmanları
dahiliyeciler bize ne diyor bazal
metabolizmanızı ölçtürün Bu bazal
metabolizma üzerinde kalori alırsanız
vücudunuza kilo alırsınız Az alırsanız
kilo verirsiniz Dolayısıyla aslında
bazal metabolizma bizim ne harcadığımızı
da gösteriyor Buna da dikkat ederiz
Gelelim beslenme ve mineral vurgusuna
Canlılar beslenme tipine göre temelde
üçe ayrılır Ototrof heterotrof hem
ototrof hem heterotrof Şimdi hem ototrof
hem heterotrof olan canlıya tek bir
örnek bileceksiniz arkadaşlar Ögülena
başka bir şey değil Bakın ögülen bakın
Ögülena burada kamçılı bir protist
kendisi eğer ışık varsa fotosentez yapar
besinini üretir Yoksa dışarıdan besin
alır Bakın dışarıdan besin alması onun
heterotrof özelliği Hayır hocam kendi
besinini üretti Fotosentez yaptı Bu onun
ototrof özelliğidir Demek ki övgülenanın
dışında bir şey bilmeyeceksin Ben
biliyorum şu anda senin aklından böcek
kapan bitkisi geliyor Hayır arkadaşlar o
böcekçil bitkiler ototroftur Hem ototrof
hem heteretrof değildir Lütfen unutmayın
Geldim heteretrof canlıya kendi besinini
üretemeyecek Bakın kendi besinini
üretemez Bu dışarı bağımlıdır Kim
olabilir hocam bunlar örneklerini
verelim Mesela saprotrof canlılar
Saprotrof çürükçül canlılar Maddeleri
çürütecekler Açığa çıkan maddeleri alıp
kullanacaklar Ya da parazit canlılar
arkadaşlar Ya da içinde mantar kelimesi
geçen hayvan kelimesi geçen canlılar
heterotrof canlılardır Yani dışa
bağımlıdır Kendi besini üretemez Siz
fotosentez yapabiliyor musunuz hayır
hocam İnsan nerede hayvanlar alemin
içerisinde Hayvanlar heteretroftur
Mantarlar heteretroftur ÖSYM sever
Mantar başlığının altına kocaman
yazacağız Bunlar heterotroftur diye
Karbondoks özümlemesi yapamazlar Mesela
karbondoks özümlemesi demek ne demek
fotosentez ya da kemosentez demek Geldim
ototrof canlılara kendi besinini
üretecek Mesela kim bu fotosentez
yapanlar
ya da ileride çok ileride öğreneceksiniz
kemosentez yapanlar Mesela kemosentezin
vurgusunda şöyle bir şey var arkadaşlar
İnorganik bileşikleri oksitliyorlar
Açığa çıkan enerjiyi besin sentezinde
kullanıyorlar Şimdilik sadece bu
kadarını bileceksiniz inorganik bileşiği
oksitliyor Açığa çıkan enerjiyle besin
üretiyor Fotosenteze baktığınız zaman
ışık enerjisiyle besin üretiyor
Peki hocam kim bunlar mesela
siyanobakteri olabilir
alger olabilir
bitkiler olabilir
mor kükürt bakterileri olabilir
Çok detay değil mi bütün biyolojiden
bahsediyoruz çünkü Önemli değil Hepsini
şu anda duyuyoruz Strese girme
Siyanobakteri alg ve bitkiler ve hatta
öglenen şöyle yazalım Fotosentez
tepkimeleri sırasında su kullanır ve
açığa oksijen çıkartır Atmosferin
oluşmasını sağlayan canlılar bunlar işte
Özellikle okyanuslarda yaşayan tek
hücreli fotosentetik canlılar Mor kükürt
bakterileri hidrojen sülfür kullanır
Açığa kükürt çıkartır Birazdan bunu da
toparlayacağız Mesela her fotosentez
tepkimesi sırasında oksijen açığa çıkar
mı çıkmaz Hatta şimdi çok daha
karizmatik bir cümleye hazır mısın
sence bütün bitkiler fotosentez
yapabilir mi
hayır hocam yapamaz Bütün bitkiler
fotosentez
yapar mı cevap hayır Kim bunlar hocam
tam parazit bitkiler Yapamaz arkadaşlar
Tam parazit bitkiler Cin saçı canavar
otu Bunlar fotosentez yapamaz Bakın
gördüğünüz gibi sizi çok ama çok
ilerideki bir konuya da hazırlıyor bu
konu Tekrar tekrar söyleyeceğim Tamam
hocam anladık Evet burada biyolojinin
özetini yapıyorsun ama korkmalı mıyım
hayır korkmana gerek yok Devam Solunum
ve fermentasyon Şimdi 9 sınıf okul
kitabı sayfa 19 Sayfanın en alt sol
tarafına baktığınızda çok tatlı bir
cümle göreceksiniz diyecek ki size
"Solunum dediğin şey oksijenli ve
oksijensizdir
Glikolis kreps ve elektron taşıma
sisteminin görüldüğü tepkimeler Şimdi o
son satırda yazan can alıcı cümleyi
kuruyorum Fermentasyon
solunum değildir
Elektron taşıma sistemi vesaire yok ETS
olmadan
ATP üretim sürecidir
Bakın kocaman yazıyorum Şuraya da
yazıyorum Fermentasyon eşit değildir
Oksijensiz solunum Solunum başka bir şey
arkadaşlar Solunum glikoliz kreps
elektron taşıma sistemi gibi
tepkimelerle enerji üretim süreciyken
fermentasyonda bir glikoliz olacak Bir
de son ürün tepkimeleri olacak Başka bir
şey olmayacak Ve okul kitabımızın
vurgusu şu: ETS olmadan ATP üretmek
fermentasyona giriyor Anlaştık mı sona
doğru geliyorum Adaptasyon Doğa en
uyumlu bireylerin ayakta kalmasını
sağlar Doğa geçmişe bakar ve der ki
"Geçmişte bir buzul çağı oldu ya da
geçmişte bir sıcaklık yükselmesi oldu Bu
bu canlı ayakta kaldı Diğerleri yok oldu
O zaman şu anda da bu canlı ayakta
kalsın" der bir şekilde bir doğal
seçilim yapar Dolayısıyla biz burada
aslında adaptasyonların doğal seçilim
sonucu olduğunu ve kalıtsal olduğunu
göreceğiz Yani sizin bir özelliğiniz
varsa bu özelliği yavrunuza
geçiriyorsunuz Bu işte adaptasyondur
Kimle kıyaslıyorlar kalıtım konusunda
modifikasyonla kıyaslıyorlar Yaz hocam
modifikasyon da buraya Ne demek
modifikasyon şöyle yazalım Modifikasyon
genlerin
ifadesinin değişmesidir Genlerin
ifadesinin değişmesidir Yani mesela
benim güneş altında bronzlaşmam beni
ilgilendirir Herhangi bir uzvumda
meydana gelen hasar beni ilgilendirir
Çocuğuma aktarılmaz Ancak adaptasyonda
mesela benim genlerimle alakalı bir şey
olduğu için yavruya aktarılma ihtimali
vardır Tabii ki hocam şimdi benim her
özelliğim yavruya aktarılır tarzında bir
cümle çıkmasın ortaya Göz rengim yeşil
ama benim çocuklarımın göz rengi yeşil
değil Ben burada daha böyle hayatta
tutan bizi ortamda kesinlikle hocam yok
olmaktan engelleyen faktörlerden
bahsediyorum Mesela örnek verelim
buzulların üzerindeki kutup ayıları
Kutup ayılarının rengi
beyaz değil mi avından avcısından ki
zaten avcısı yok artık ama en azından
avından kendini saklamış oluyor Başka ne
olabilir hocam mesela sürüngenlere
bakalım Sürüngenler kara canlılarıdır ve
kara canlıları arkadaşlar idrar olarak
aslında ne atarlar ürik asit kristalleri
atarlar Ürik asit atmak susuz bir idrar
yapmak demektir Ve sen kara canlısıysan
senin için suyun olmaması büyük bir
problemdir Ama balıklara bakıyorsun
balık amonyak atıyor Hocam amonyakı bol
suyla atılır Zaten adam suyun içerisinde
değil mi öyleyse benim hayatta kalmama
neden olacak özellikler ve yavruma
aktarılan özellikler aslında bir nevi
adaptasyon ifadesidir Lütfen unutmayalım
Bakın burada bir canlının elinin kolunun
aldığı şekil gösterilmiş Mesela bir
kertenkeleyi düşünün tavanda
yürüyebiliyor Neden o şekilde bir
anatomik yapıya sahip Yani dolayısıyla
bulunduğu ortama uyum sağlamış ve bu
şekilde hayatta kalmış Belki de
zamanında onu avlamak isteyen canlılar
oraya ulaşamıyordu Ve bu onun için ne
oldu arkadaşlar bir avantaj oldu Bu
şekilde düşüneceğiz Modifikasyonlar
kalıtsal mıdır hocam kalıtsal
değil şeklinde yorum yapabilirsiniz
Üreme canlılık faaliyetleri için zorunlu
olmayan neslin devamını sürdürebilmek
için yapılan davranıştır Güzel Benim
burada en çok dikkat çekmek istediğim
şey şu Kalıtsal yapının korunduğu bir
eşeysiz üreme var
Çeşitliliğin sağlandığı bir eşeyli üreme
var Ancak lütfen dikkat Eşeyli üremeyi
eşeysiz üremeden ayıran en temel özellik
döllenme var Bakın eşeysiz üremede
döllenme yoktur Buna ek olarak
söylenebilecek en güzel cümleyi
söylüyorum şimdi Mayoz
tek başına
bir üreme tipine
eşeyli demeye yetmez
Yani siz gittiniz dediniz ki hocam ama
bu üreme tipinde mayoz var eşeyli
olmasın Hayır Döllenme var mı sorusunu
soracaksın Yoksa eşeyli değildir Örnek
verir misin hocam ileriden partenogenez
Partenogenez nedir döllenmemiş
yumurtadan birey oluşması Mesela erkek
arılar öyle oluşuyor Partenogenez bir
eşeysiz üremedir Mayoz var Halbuki erkek
arılarda çeşitlilik var Yetmez hocam
Döllenme olacak Eşeyli eşeysiz
ayrımındaki en temel şey bir şeye eşeyli
üreme demen için ne lazım döllenme varsa
eşeyli üremedir diyeceksin ve olayı
noktalayacaksın Son başlık ölüm
bu okul kitabında yok arkadaşlar ve ben
buraya her nefis ölümü tadacaktır
yazmışım Ben her zaman şunu söylerim
Biliyorsunuz benim öğrencilerimin
görüşü bakışı davranışı öncelikle onları
ilgilendirir Yani dolayısıyla hep
esprinde yaparım ya istersen krem
peynire tap Bu seni ilgilendirir Şimdi
bazen bazı bilim insanları şöyle
cümleler kurabiliyor Ölüm her canlı için
ortak olmayabilir Ya da bir gün canlılar
ölümsüz olacak Tamam olabilir Ama ben
insan özelinde konuşayım Şimdi belki bir
sanalemi aktarıldığında evet ölümsüzlük
bulunabilir ama organik bedenler için
insan bedeni için ölümsüzlük mümkün
değildir arkadaşlar Sadece biyolojik
olarak düşünüyoruz ya işte DNA'nın tamir
mekanizması ya da birtım enzimlerin
faaliyetleri vesaire Hocam radyoaktif
maddeler ne olacak vücudumuzda yarılanma
ömrü belli sürelerde olan maddeler ne
olacak bir de arkadaşlar ben bu maddeyi
çıkaramam Çünkü benim işim ölümle Yani
ben her gün ölümü gören bir insanım Ben
ölü bedenle çalışan bir insanım Yani
hayatımın bir parçası bu Barış hocanız
kadavra ile çalışan bir insan ve böyle
bir gerçek varken hım ölüm canların
karakteristik özelliği düşünmektense ben
bu kavramı önüme koyarım ve bununla
birlikte yaşarım Çünkü dediğim gibi
arkadaşlar bu kavram benim hayatımın bir
parçası ve evet benim için her nefis
ölümü tadacaktır ifadesi çok anlamlı bir
ifadedir Evet çayınızı kahvenizi
tazeleyin Bir mola ikinci videoda
virüsleri işleyeceğiz